who was reagan
and how did reagan come to his political
conclusions of eventually obviously
becoming the president
of the united states well so he was
he had been raised an fdr democrat he
called himself a hemophiliac liberal
a bleeding heart liberal he was a new
dealer from the midwest
and i mean that's my family too my
family's from western pennsylvania
coal mine steel mills pittsburgh and you
know in those days they it was kind of
the party of god
guns and labor in those days right
um it's interesting that's what donald
trump really tapped into
here in western pennsylvania fracking
industry west virginia
coal mining but uh so ronald reagan came
out of that group his mother was
very religious very very religious
and when reagan went out to hollywood in
the 1930s started making movies a lot of
movies
1930s and 1940s among other things he
became weary of
of kind of this hyper new deal
collectivism
redistributionism high tax rate
tax rates were reagan called creeping
socialism
where you start this new program that
new program this new program pretty soon
how do we pay for all of this well how
do you pay for it
well you increase taxes right on who on
the rich
all right well how do you get any higher
than 91
well we go to 94 right how about 99.5
right yeah margaret thatcher said the
problem with socialism is you eventually
run out of other people's money
at some point so that got to reagan and
what really got to reagan
was he saw the communist infiltration
of hollywood reagan saw that with the
screen actors guild he was president of
the screen actors guild
and he also saw reagan became a popular
after dinner speaker
in hollywood in the 1940s where he would
go around giving the speech
excoriating nazism
fascism and one day after he gave this
speech
to a men's group at his church the
pastor of the reverend cleveland
kleihauer came up to reagan and said
hey ron that's a great speech you know
nazism fascism evil
evil evil evil evil you know hitler's
dead
there's no movement in the united states
at all for nazism you know the war was
over three years ago
you know ron out there right now there's
another threat out there it's called
communism
and it's it's pretty brutal too and i
think your speech should be a lot more
powerful if maybe you just added in a
little criticism about communism
and reagan patrick said well that's a
pretty good idea i think i'll start
doing that
so reagan gives his typical stump speech
and he's giving it to one of these
progressive groups in washington right
and
sitting there you know the john howard
lawson dalton trumbo hollywood ten types
way to go ron way to go you know get
those nazis get those fascists and then
reagan gets the end of the speech
he writes about this in his memoirs and
he said at the end of the speech
he said he said you know there's another
ism out there and it's called communism
another totalitarianism and i'll tell
you if that ever
becomes a threat to the united states
like nazism was
i will condemn that just as harshly and
patrick reagan said you could hear a pin
drop
a pin drop right and and he said
he got called names um
witch hunter red baiter fascist scum
all of a sudden he's like persona
non-grad he's like what am i doing
and he realized reagan said the reds
weren't under the bed you know they were
they were in the bed
and a lot of these progressive groups
that he thought were good-hearted
liberals like him
were actually pro-communists so if this
a
awakened reagan to the communist threat
in hollywood
and the united states and all of that
that fdr
everything else began pushing him out of
the democratic party
and toward eventually the republican
party in conservatism
so if you like this sort of short club
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye